when my older daughter was a teenager
she said to me she was scared to come
home from the tube station and told me
horror stories about attacks on people
she knew and a scourge of knife crime in
the country isn't getting better it's
getting worse over the last five years
the number of teenagers being treated
for knife wounds has risen by fifty five
percent this week West Midlands Police
released a new anti knife crime campaign
featuring a man jailed for life for
murder when he was a schoolboy a video
of his story is being shown in schools
across Birmingham but will this really
make a difference to kids carrying
weapons while offensives have risen the
number of police officers has plummeted
to a record low the number one priority
of any government should be the security
of its citizens so Prime Minister Boris
Johnson is doing just the right thing in
committing to recruiting 20,000 police
officers in the next three years knife
crime causes catastrophic damage to
families with tragic consequences we
need more police and tougher sentences
[Music]
Karen I sense were on the same page I've
got a couple of questions I'd like to
put you before that you mentioned that
video let me just say what West Midlands
Police say about the video then we'll
see a bit of it we've not taken the
decision to produce the video lightly we
understand the severity of this brutal
crime we're not seeking to glorify his
actions the aim is to demonstrate the
very real consequences of being armed
with a weapon using a real life
experience this video has had no impact
on the length of Saddam's custodial
sentence let's take a look at some of it
when actually to think about it you
don't need that knife I know a lot of
the times I used to think I'm protecting
myself but what am i protecting myself
from having to live with the feeling
that I've taken a life trust me it's not
nice especially one Union so on your own
all night and you've got nothing else to
do you're gonna be thinking about these
things and they come to haunt you
I've been in jail for years and since
I've been in jail I mother
Leah's sister I've had a niece and a
nephew Anthony it's hard I don't want
you to do it
or don't want no one to go through what
I'm going through
Sodom essa kill who murders someone with
the knife aged 15 speaking in that video
released by West Midlands Police couple
things question one I do do you support
that video they've been forced on the
back for a little bit I think it's a
good idea question ii i'm wholly
supportive of boris johnson recruiting
more police i was i very much doubt
anybody's in say here's my fear you
don't want necessarily want the first
twenty thousand men or women through the
door we mustn't allow i think we have a
pretty damn good police force in rushing
people to get them in we must make sure
that we get all the standards they don't
slip at all and it's not the first
twenty thousand through the door that we
sign up answers of those two if you look
yes that the fact that they put out this
video of somebody who initially by the
way he showed no remorse or regret when
he was arrested and convicted it's now
these years later that he seems to be
contrite he seems to now have really
regretted and he had himself in of
course just to hit thank you Jan
genuinely has shown remorse and is
saying please to others don't do this
you don't want to be where I am and if
one life can be saved
Congress video it's worth it and his
family by the way even even his family
have said it if only we had done more as
a family must push the sister of the
victim said if this saves one life it's
worth it we mustn't we mustn't portion
the first twenty thousand because they
are is not just twenty thousand more
kind of taking new coppers off the
streets they're doing a lot more and
that this is what they're saying we're
working with the police to tackle
violent crime giving them new powers to
seize dangerous weapons making it easier
to you stop and search and recruiting
twenty thousand new officers over the
next three years we're also investing
over two hundred and twenty million into
early intervention projects to stop
people from committing crime in the
first place so the there's lots of
there's an operation going on this week
got operations Skepta which I think this
video which i think is a very good thing
is associated with it's about when I saw
that video I thought it was very
powerful I thought it would act as a
deterrent in no way celebrated or
glorified this truck this this child he
was fifteen when he went into prison
but what about more you know what about
retail and why should supermarkets sell
them any knives at all to under-21s
why can't you security tag knife so
anybody has to say why they need it you
know if there's lots more that can be
done about the you know stop bins for
knives and so on I can say it's not so
why it's not gonna stop no I agree
that's not gonna sentence you know the
average custodial sentence for an iPhone
or an offensive weapon is eight months
it's pitiful it's stupid you know and
I'd like you out watch this video and I
thought it was incredibly powerful I
think the way he talked about wasted
lies not only his own not only the
victims but the family man and his
family of abandoned he's alone but my
warriors every time the police or the
government tried to do something about
knife crime they instantly bombarded
with objections from people playing
grievance politics you know with the
usual suspects you know who I'm talking
about they come up and say that whatever
measures the cops try to put forward to
limit knife crime they'll come out and
say racist punitive you mean I've
stopped and searched well yes that's one
of the things but but they do what
whatever the police put forward and I
think that's the problem and so we play
grievance politics and nothing changes
nothing gets done great whatever well I
certainly don't think the longest
sentences whether they you should have
longer sentences for other reasons but I
don't think that we ended talent I don't
think anyone takes an iPhone month and
looks at oh I could get six months or I
could get no much I could get a team I
just don't think that sort of deterrent
works to the sort of people you're
talking about I thought this was I quite
admire the police for doing this because
I thought it's interesting let's see if
it has any impact at all I hope someone
is doing a proper piece of research and
let's see does this have any impact yeah
well I mean you're gonna have to try
lots of different things
can we just hear from somebody am at an
inner-city posture who is opening safe
houses across South London it is
embarrassing for any country or city and
in the advanced city to our 15 year olds
dying on the street and all we do is to
just make statements or complaints and
so the safe houses
they are not just like I said before
they need we need more of it I think we
have about 23 itself on their houses all
over London right now I've had to remove
people from East London and put them in
South overnight otherwise they would die
before the days over or they would cure
someone good for him I think there are
creative community based measures that
are also used in joint conjunction with
this it is not just the increase in the
police officers but look the statistics
are staggeringly frightening forty-three
thousand five hundred sixteen knife
crime offences in the 12 months to March
2019 an 80 percent increase in five
years two hundred and eighty-five
killings in 2017 18 the highest since
1946 but the government has lost control
of this area and enough is enough we've
got to come down very hard the 20,000
need to be recruited the right officers
do you say you disagree with critical
and you think longer sentence I think
that there I think the sentences need to
be appropriate for what is a really
dangerous tragic situation and it
government has lost control where the
neighborhood police officers that we
used to see I don't see them around
anymore we need visible policing as well
but that's it they're very different
issues all I'm saying is I do not
believe long you might want longer
sentences because there's a punishment
but I don't believe the longer sentences
are going to be a deterrent I don't
think it'll make any difference at all I
would like to think it would make an
impact I think the bottom line is kids
feel invincible ironically because
they're carrying knives so they're going
to say he got caught we won't it's one
of those things I didn't think that what
I'd like to it makes a difference does
we think it's powerful but I don't think
so to put this into context he is
serving a very long prison sentence for
murder there were 43 thousand plus knife
crimes
many of them are let off with a caution
always though there has to be a
deterrent there has to be a deterrent to
stop it the impact of neighborhood
policing would be Karen oh it what one
the visible deterrent that is roaming
around the reveal be there when a crime
is committed you know they so get they
also get to communicate with the
community they get information they will
be able to make use of these safe houses
they will be able to work with the
community
and there's no shortcut to doing that
and of course a lot of this is now
happening to social media this is linked
to the county lines and the drugs
problem that we have as well this is all
interconnected and the more police
officers we have in the community the
better it will be for the country